let's pick up where we left off we were
um
midway through or not way through
introducing
circular motion right so for the benefit
of those who weren't here or those whose
brains have
you know vacated the premises since
yesterday let's just remember
where did we begin we went outside we
did our demonstration
and we looked at some vectors we looked
at them visually and we saw that was
cool
but we saw well visually is nice but we
want something a little more
concrete and manipulable than that right
so what we did was we started to think
about the horizontal and vertical
components
of an object that is moving in
make sure i don't hurt anyone moving in
a circle okay so we want to understand
this we want to see what's going on and
so we thought okay
as with projectile motion we thought
about horizontal and vertical components
and then we could go from there
right so do you remember for
displacement what were our horizontal
and vertical equations we had an x
equals and a y
equals x is equal to
we thought parametrics right r times
cos theta we'll get to omega in a second
right omega comes in when we have to do
the rate of change down to the next step
conversely y coordinate you're going to
get r sine theta
good so this is where we began now as
usual
when you go from displacement to
velocity to acceleration you're
differentiating with respect to
time but then we noticed that that's not
in terms of time
it's in terms of theta so we had to do a
little bit of chain rule fancy footwork
okay
but you may remember what we ended up
with was we used our
omega right and you remember what was
omega about what what quantity
is that
omega is about angular velocity
right in other words it's the change in
the angle as you're going around
okay so just to remind you that was d
theta on dt
okay so we got this result sorry i
should have said dx on dt
and then you can play the similar kind
of game with y
your vertical velocity right
and this is r sine theta so you don't
get a negative out the front you're just
getting r
omega cos theta okay
so i think that's where i left you
yesterday
right when you're going down the ladder
and you're differentiating with just
with respect to time again
you have to do the same kind of thing
you've got to introduce omega again
because you're still not with respect to
time
okay so you're getting this is the
second derivative we'll do the x's first
so it's just the derivative of this
derivative with respect to time of minus
r omega sine theta right the radius
and the angular velocity in uniform
circular motion that's what this is all
about
they're both constants so i'm just going
to rip them at the front
minus r omega okay and simultaneously i
don't want to differentiate with respect
to time
i want to differentiate with respect to
theta right so i do this
i say well let's make that with respect
to theta
i've got a sine theta in there but to
compensate
i need to multiply by d theta on dt
there's the chain rule thing happening
there so your d theta
you can't the d thetas d cancel your
theta's cancel
leave you with that dt that you had with
at the start so far so good
that's just omega that omega is going to
come out here it'll become
minus r omega squared
and then the derivative of the sine is
just cos
that's good okay now you can do exactly
the same thing over here
i'm just going to kind of skip it
because it's relatively trivial
right similarly it's going to be exactly
the same except with
cos instead of sines and so on you're
going to get d
squared y on dt squared the vertical
acceleration okay it's going to be minus
r
omega squared you do the same thing and
that cos is going to turn two-way sign
okay so then there's only a quick hop
from acceleration to force what's the
difference between acceleration and
force
mass good so we're just going to
multiply so
this is we traditionally call these you
know f for force
but i've got two different forces here
and in a second i'm going to get two
more
right so i'm going to call this the x
one and the y one just so i can
distinguish
and it's just gonna be this times mass
forces mass times acceleration
right so you're getting minus m
r omega squared that and
minus m r me squared
that cool this is good